your multi-billion dollar company how
about this why don't you take three
commercials don't do them that nobody
watches and let's hire nine people to
actually care about your end user
what a concept how are we gonna do this
I don't know stop throwing cash down the
toilet how are you gonna do this maybe
you don't buy a Yellow Pages ad this
year guys you don't need it promise
you're better off going doing smoke
signals at the top of the building
commercials have 80 billion dollars in
ad spend a year mainly with the Fortune
500 companies those companies are now
especially with a looming recession
coming finally starting to understand
that when they run a commercial on a
sitcom or a reality show on cable that
they are taking good cash and lighting
it on fire and throwing it in the
garbage and I can tell you because I'm
in the trenches the biggest companies in
the world are about to reallocate their
money much more into social than
television